hello, welcome to a new edition of
las vegas now in spanish health to
natalie has kept today we start with
the latest in the world of
entertainment from batman and
adventure and it is that their new collaboration
is called i returned and it is sweeping the
world of  music with this new hit
which is a mixture of triple bad bank and
with the adventure bachatera ballad I think
it is also made us feel that I
was back without type year 2005
well I came back ranks first in
several musical billboards including
enapu music you can see  the complete video
on youtube and if you want and if you are
we were born a super fan of batman and this
state you can enjoy the bad bank and
night in the booking world in the link
where the dj will entertain the night with the
artist's biggest hits
this event is for  people over
18 years of age for more information visit
spoke to goal.com
ok a music festival that if you
like Arabic music like I do it will move
you and you will be  Today I am talking about the
lovers and friends festival with
performances by various
iconic artists such as usher ludacris baby bass
nina sky and much more lovers en friends it
will take place in May next year but
tickets for this event are already
on sale for more information visit
lovers and friends fest  puntocom
and for fans of
country music ribamar cantar and the duo bourges
in tan announced the final dates of
their residency in their endorsements together in
vega soto diaz there's together in vegas
rather the music residency with its
most successful in the city will take place
From December 1 to 15, tickets go on
sale this Friday, August 5 via
ticketmaster dotcom.
Well, before I say goodbye, let me
introduce you to the magical world of Change. This
is a town full of Christmas lights,
as you can see, that will come to our
city.  for the first time during the
holidays
in las vegas' i go because it's a
winter wonderland from  from
november 26 to january 2 for more
information visit in sant crist more
dotcom
well here I come to your las
vegas edition spanish side thank you very much for
your attention see you next week
greets you natalia bad sound
[Music]